hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast Q&A livestream our 30th sorry
for the shenanigans there with the timer
in advance of coming back
we have termites I am told in our
computer so anyway that's causing some
difficulty but I think we got it licked
well what we did is we got an anteater
and it's gonna all right I've always
wanted an anteater yeah you know
actually it could be kind of an
interesting pet not very smart but
friendly mostly yeah trendy is that what
you said trundling know that too yeah
not so trendy no well not yet we could
start it I should alright we're gonna
start by answering a few questions that
were particularly interesting that we
missed last time and actually there were
two from two times ago that we missed
one of them about a thread that someone
want us to go back and look at but the
tweet in question has been deleted so we
can't do that apologies to Matt the next
one though is from Ryan sent a patreon
message about guerrilla artwork he says
as someone still drenched in the filth
of our societal subterfuge what siren of
truth can I sound without simultaneously
amplifying my perceived ethical
shortcomings what to be honest I'm not
entirely sure what that means I hate
strongly with it but I don't know what
it means
yeah so I would be able to find his
grill artwork no I was not able to find
your grill are what can I did look I
looked in several places including on
patreon and I couldn't the interface I
have to say it's kind of cruddy there's
no search yeah it is
so anyway hey patreon get your act
together
but yeah if you want to send word of
what I'm looking for a gorilla or
work-wise I'd be happy to look at it in
terms of advice I would say look you're
the artist
right that's a really important role I
think what I would do is maybe try not
to second-guess yourself so much if you
think there's a thread that we need to
be paying attention to and you know how
to make us see it with gorilla artwork
then you know explore and you'll
discover so
anyway more power to you all right next
question from last time my mother is 75
and I've tried to further explain unity
2020
she doesn't understand dual governing
she keeps saying people don't work
together tips on what I can say shall be
on board if she gets it it's a classic
yeah it is cool message look I think
people do work together I think we're
not used to seeing it because we're used
to seeing them in zero sum or negative
sum dynamics which brings out the worst
in people but if you set up a team and
the idea is the success condition looks
like can you figure out how to navigate
together then people don't want to find
themselves in failure condition what's
more I mean maybe this is the crux of
the matter we are so far away from
policy that works in the interests of
most people that doing better than we
are doing is actually easy right if all
you did was sweep away the corrupting
influences then figuring out what would
be in the interests of the American
public is easy at first there comes a
point at which you've done all the stuff
that makes sense right and then you can
have disagreements about whether you
want to prioritize this value or that
value but until you get to all the basic
stuff that needs to just work then
there's no point in arguing right good
people who have heard the various inputs
to the decision-making process will be
able to reach agreement they may not
nail it right they may pick a second
best healthcare solution rather than the
absolute best one because it's
impossible to know enough to get it
exactly right but the point is a second
best health care solution would be about
a billion times better than the cruddy
one we have now so the point is yeah
let's get to one of the good ones and
then we can argue about whether or not
we got it exactly right and then we can
you know fight about ideology but at the
moment the ideology is hey let's have
some policy that serves us because
that's what it's supposed to do next one
is a comment says Unity 2020 is
politically naive it would elect a wet
centrist and change nothing as a
founding member of the first against the
wall' Club I say Bret should run or we
kick him out of the club it's all very
kind are you trying to get me killed no
it's not it's not about centrist
I'm gonna say this very clearly because
I think this is important first of all I
have no patience with centrist and I am
very frequently the person challenging
the whole idea of centrism because I
think it's absurd however the center is
where we meet all right the Patriotic
center is where we meet to talk about
the immediate interests of the nation
right we can you know if you're on a
ship and it is sinking because it is
taking on water then the point is you
put aside your differences about ship
design and you deal with the question of
how do we get the water to leave the
ship faster than its coming in right
that's what the center looks like it
doesn't mean that the people involved in
the bilge mechanism don't have an idea
about how you might construct a ship
that would prevent this from happening
in the future they might but in the
meantime the ship is taking on water
everybody grab a bucket and let's deal
with the immediate problem right by
putting aside our ideological
differences which frankly if we talk
about them now they're gonna get us
killed with struggle sessions emerging
in the workplace this is a huge
opportunity for actual liberals to
resurrect a label organization labor
organization to protect workers I think
even many conservatives could be brought
on board I like this idea I'm not sure
how actionable it is it seems like the
resurrection of anything that is
traditionally liberal right now is going
to be met with some some pretty fierce
offense from anyone who's observing
what's going on the farm pseudo left and
conflating that with the left more
broadly yeah I agree and I think in some
sense what we're talking about is a 2.0
version of something that labor unions
tried to do and failed to do largely in
this country it's not that they didn't
succeed they accomplished a great deal
but they also became corrupt and
sluggish and an obstacle to to positive
change in many cases so what we're
looking for is something I mean look we
offshored
the jobs that traditionally go along
with labor unions most of them right
we've still got you know police and
teachers and stuff like that but in
general the manufacturing jobs that were
the bulk of the unionized
kurz are all gone so in some sense we
have to figure out what to do to protect
the people who were once in union
izybelle jobs who are now in cruddy or
jobs we have to resurrect some sort of
useful sector for people to to work in
if work is even the right model or to be
productive in might be better but I
think in some sense all of this stuff I
mean the problem with Bernie all right
the problem with Bernie is that all of
his solutions are backward looking right
the backward is not where we're gonna
find the right solution for the 21st
century so although I mean to be fair
this question doesn't actually use the
word Union right it says resurrect okay
that appears to be thinking about
something that's already been done but
labor organization and you know the idea
of protecting the rights of workers
against that of the employers is not
inherently a backward facing idea well I
would put it differently I would say the
problem is that we have a system in
which corruption advances the interests
of what once might have been called
management against the interests of what
what once might have been called labor
so that artificial advantage in the
political sphere to management is a
hazard to everybody what you really want
to do is level the playing field so that
everybody's interests as citizens are
advanced by the system that is to say
everybody who's in management is also a
citizen all right they're interesting to
get taken care of but their interest
don't get priority and so I think the
point is labor is actually the wrong
place for this to exist it was a place
that it could exist by virtue of the
fact that it organized people in a in a
way that allowed them to become
politically affiliated but I think in
some sense it was a partial solution to
a problem that needs a complete solution
yep okay so one remaining question from
last time before we get to today's
questions how do you been totally
different topic how do you feel about
the legal and ethical hunting of animals
in North America I have a good reason
for asking this question lol so we
aren't told what the good reason for
asking a question is but the question is
how do we feel about the legal and
ethical hunting of animals on earth
where of course
putting the word ethical there is maybe
ants you know it's a little bit of a
strange addition but maybe the idea just
is hunting that is currently within the
balance of the law and is done in a way
that say most reasonable people would
see as ethical yeah
well I think I think a lot in jizan
what's meant by ethical here because on
the one hand in principle I have no
objection to people hunting in practice
there are lots of things about the way
hunting is done that I think are very
objectionable and the fact that we have
destroyed so much habitat for the kinds
of creatures that are worth hunting
means that this is a very different
puzzle because it's inherently in some
sense a sport for the few so yea though
it's also true where I thought you were
going there is was because we've because
we've managed to clear the habitat
largely of the carnivores that would be
eating the kinds of things that we tend
to hunt not not us but you know deer and
elk and and such that there is calling
that needs to happen because the culling
that would be happening by the Predators
that we've already eradicated isn't
happening and so to some degree hunters
are doing a job that is mandated by our
already poor decisions over the last
hundred years I do agree with that right
I mean it's also true you know we I
think you did too but I certainly I
often had students who were hunters and
would sometimes bring bring meat you
know gift gift me meat to get you know
gift us meat and it was wonderful
hearing these guys always guys you know
they often were hunting with with their
wives or girlfriends or female friends
but you know I assume that hunting
excuse very male and as it happens all
of my students who were hunters who with
whom I talked about it were male talking
to them about their stories of being out
out in nature of doing regular annual or
seasonal hunts either alone or with
groups of friends that they always did
they always did the same that went to
the same place they had
they had this tradition built around it
was extraordinary from several
perspectives not just the social aspect
you know the the the bonding between
human beings that they could look
forward to all year and know that it was
going to happen again
but also the being out in nature and you
know it's it's it's no secret in most
circles that actually people who hunt
and fish are some of the most ardent
conservationists because they see what
encroaching of development on habitat
does to habitat in populations and such
so you know those those two huge
benefits where the action itself is is
hunting was it's extraordinary
and yes so long as the hunting is done
ethically you know meaning you know
meaning a lot of things I guess well I
mean I think the problem is that it
means a lot of things right bow hunting
in some sense is more organic the
advantage over the animal is less on the
other hand I'm guessing that the
likelihood of a wounded animal running
off with an arrow in it and suffering
and I don't know perhaps escaping and
suffering you think it might be greater
with bow hunting done was done I don't
know I'd be curious I guess we're about
to find out because I'm out just set it
live on the internet to thousands of
people but but I would say I think
actually a frank conversation needs to
happen more much more troubling than bow
hunting of various kinds of DRL
concluded to me would be things like
bear baiting which was an issue when we
lived in Michigan so people would bait
bears and the Bears would come to the
bait and people would shoot them and I
frankly I find that completely barbaric
and now I'm told by people no less than
Joe Rogan that bears are actually
problematic animals that aren't so cool
I disagree with this but nonetheless I
get that there is something deeper here
than a desire to you know
to just kill cool stuff but but to be
honest personally and I'm not sure that
I can defend this completely but I'm
more troubled with the killing of
creatures that are slower to reproduce
and smarter and you know a bear is a
highly intelligent animal and so I am
more troubled by its trauma than I am a
deer probably because deer are built to
live shorter lives and be more likely to
be predated upon it's convenient and
maybe no accident that that Maps very
neatly on to predator versus prey and
that you know the carnivores that are
out there that are predators of the more
usual things that people hunt deer and
elk and rabbits and and such duck I
guess
bears don't hunt duck do they that it's
also the meat of carnivores also isn't
nearly as tasty or or nutritious or safe
for us to eat in you and something like
you don't eat the liver of a carnivore
that's actually like really not good for
you
and so you know eating carnivores are
effectively second-order herbivores the
closer to herbivore you get closer to
first order herbivore you get the better
the meat is for you and and tastier so
just like you shouldn't be eating human
meat you shouldn't meeting bear meat or
lion meat or anything and so if you're
not eating it what are you doing why why
are you killing it yeah my guess would
be that we need to have a rethink of
hunting that involves a resurrection of
our appreciation for wilderness and an
extension of it so that it there's more
of it and then a question about what to
the extent there is hunting what should
people be hunting with you know should
they be firing lead into the wilderness
probably not you know high powered
weapons is that a good idea what weapons
are most humane I don't know but we
should be having that conversation and
I'm pretty sure we're not yeah
okay first question from the livestream
that just ended this is just a
logistical question really is there a
way we can document in writing your
conversation with a black intellectual
roundtable I see it as possibly one of
those brainstorming charts with each
individual's response thank you both for
what you do I'll support you in any way
I can so this person is asking for some
kind of basically a transcript which we
don't have the ability to do at this
point but it's possible that YouTube is
going to do that automatically if
they're not perfect but it does a decent
job of subtitling which could easily
become a transcript so I don't frankly I
don't know if that setting is on or not
I will say that conversation a lots of
people have loved it which is great I'm
really I'm really excited that people
dug the conversation and then it went
well I mean I knew that it would go well
but that group of people how could it
not but I also think that it was like
just the tip of the iceberg that there
is so much to be said on many of these
topics and I am looking forward to
continuing those conversations however
it happens could be a second round table
could be individual conversations with
people present on that podcast or people
who see it and weren't present some of
whom were invited and didn't get back to
me but anyway there's lots of there's
lots of room for that conversation to be
extended and I hope to do it soon as a
psych major the inculcation of critical
theory and post-modernism is troublesome
will it eventually leave an indelible
mark on the industry's reputation is
there hope for social science how should
we comport ourselves to compat woken us
it's a lot of questions to the first one
will it leave an indelible mark on the
on the industry's reputation oh it has I
think that that ship has sailed
is there hope for social science more
broadly you know I'd say that some sub
disciplines in psych and an anthropology
are doing better than others sociology
seems to be largely captured cultural
anthropology done you know it's it's
tough I'd say it this way we've got lots
of disciplines
that are in various states of
dysfunction many of them were founded
around the right question right ecology
we found it to be not completely a
wasteland but almost a wasteland of
quality thinking and work right not
social science though oh I know but my
point is ecology is still a home for
many of the most important questions
about how creatures interact with each
other so it's sort of how evolution
happens in real time right so so the
metaphor that we would use is evolution
is the movie in ecology is the still
from the movie that you is is the way
that you have access to inferring what
the movie says right so there is a way
to do it right and maybe it will
resurrect itself and the same goes for
many of these social sciences now some
of them are just phony fields that were
made up right critical theory is a phony
nonsense field it doesn't mean there
wasn't a kernel of an idea there but
it's not one that needs vast elaboration
on the other hand social psychology for
example is a very important set of
questions fundamentally important
probably necessary to our long-term
survival that we figure out where the
pitfalls are so that we can avoid them
and there is historical work that's very
important and Milgram experiment for
example and the Asch conformity
experiment these are very important
discoveries about basically defects in
the human heuristics that we use to make
sense of the world that said all of
these disciplines seem to have lost
their way and so don't throw out the
questions right throw out the mechanism
that allowed these fields to go astray
and figure out how to bootstrap a
revitalized version of them or you know
a new version of them but it's very
important that we don't toss the
questions out because we haven't seen
productive work on those questions in
decades
I don't know how to read this one
last video opposition came to your idea
: rent seekers hoarding opportunity
cause struggle of people of color and
others what evidence proves this true
who is hoarding what is considered rent
seeking is it dangerous to label a
villain class so I think this is going
to be about the black intellectuals
Roundtable yeah
so rent seeking is self defined it is
the the earning of profit through
non-productive activity in other words
the economy is supposed to pay you for
producing something useful but there are
mechanisms where you can extract rent
you know the way a warlord does for
example right you can prevent somebody
from passing down a road they need to
pass down and so you can effectively
extort money from them and so that's
obviously illegal but there are lots of
legal ways to block people's access to
things and then charge them for access
that you did not add anything to so the
reason that I define rent seekers as the
problem is that it's self defined I am
NOT saying these people are inherently
rent seekers in fact what I have said is
in many cases you have somebody who's
contributed something important that has
made them powerful but then having
become powerful they learned to rent see
they may not even realize they're doing
it in other words they may have the
experience of what I brought important
things into the world and I've been
handsomely rewarded therefore I'm
productive right the answer is now
you're twenty percent productive and 80
percent rent-seeking or vice versa we
don't know it's going to be different in
each case but the point is it is the
rent seeking behavior that is the enemy
and to the extent that we leave niches
open where people learn how to do this
thing we have to shut those down and
that's not to say we have to zero the
accounts of people who rent seek in fact
I think the primary thing is to prevent
this behavior from continuing into the
future and the better we can get a match
between producing things that are
actually useful to the economy you know
be they services or goods or innovations
or whatever they are that we can get
those things to match the remuneration
then the system evolves in the writer
to the extent that rent-seeking is where
the money is made it evolves in a bad
direction so I would say that we have a
little breach
okay finish I think that we do have a
language problem and I am so ignorant of
economics I do not know where the term
rent-seeking emerges from and why the
term rent is is in there and what it has
to do historically with the common
parlance use of the term rent when
people pay rent to a landlord but the
fact that defund the police and cancel
rent are two of the really you know the
primary hashtags right now that are part
of this sort of you know Maoist
revolution in the streets that we're
experiencing cannot be helping when we
separately try to talk about rent
seeking behavior because people who own
property who are charging rent for the
privilege of living on that property is
you know that is not productive in the
way that generating ideas and solving
societal problems is productive but we
are also you know when you where we talk
about rent seeking we are not saying
cancel rent we're not saying get rid of
landlords we're not saying get rid of
private property and I don't know I
don't know historically why those are -
why those are the same words it's
probably the actual same word like I
don't know logically but it's going to
be confusing so I think think I know the
answer to this okay so what I'm talking
about rent seekers we're talking about
what's called economic rent now I
believe that rent in the sense of pay
your rent mm-hmm is actually yes derived
from the same concept and ultimately
this conversation goes through the
georgous the Henry George House of land
value taxation Fame so this is a very
interesting economic philosophy that
basically views everything through a
lens of land which is limited and
basically proposes a I will say a single
fix for all the ills that we see evolve
in our our economic structure in fact I
think I am correct in quoting Milton
Freeman Friedman as
describing land value taxation as the
least worst attacks something like that
least worst yeah well he wasn't a fan of
taxation yeah point is even Milton
Friedman recognized that there was
something attacks worse in the way land
functioned and so anyway I would say I
am not completely compelled by the
georgians that we have a fix that we can
derive from a single shift a massive
shift in the way we collect revenue but
I would say you will you will be
delighted if you are interested in
people who have a very interesting
perspective to which there is a great
deal and you want a a proper argument
about a simple solution to a set of
complex problems this is a place to
check out check out the George's
George's I'm also closely related and
actually probably closer to my belief
system are the pigouvian s-- so
pigouvian taxes are taxes that take
externalities and return them to their
proper owners so to the extent that you
are creating pollution that harms people
the point is your text should return
those costs to you and this is a
corrective mechanism that I believe is
as close to a single solution to all of
our biggest problems as exists now I
don't vote while not yet being anything
close to operational it's very hard to
operationalize yes but from my new tax
is inherently something that you need to
be operational right but let's just say
do it as a thought experiment oh you
have turned every cost to the person who
giant tax should be well but then what
does the system evolve into if you if
the costs if the benefits and costs of
your actions all belong to you
suddenly all kinds of obnoxious behavior
disappears yeah right if the incentive
to game the system gets decreased to
close to zero yeah heard your panel on
race talk about families this again
gonna be what went up yesterday the
intellectual black intellectual
roundtable if income potential was the
determining factor asian men would not
be least likely to be swiped right on
black women also least likely it's about
western beauty standards nope
it's about Western beauty standards
which are a heuristic for something else
something devastating something
diabolical that we are not aware of
about ourselves which is that our genes
have a complex set of interests in who
we find attractive and for what right in
other words there isn't just one thing
that people find other people attractive
for and whether you're male or female
dictates how many things you are likely
to find people attractive for and the
calculus of who you should be attracted
to for these different things is
distinct so you know if it were Western
beauty standards then Asian men and
Asian women I mean it is a big place but
let's just say you would expect the same
valence on the decision-making and in
fact what you find oh no that's that's a
that's an ungenerous interpretation of
the statement what did I misunderstand
beauty standards does not presume that
the West for any given population call
it Asia which obviously is not a single
population has the same beauty snares
for men and women has the same
expectations of what is beauty and and
and such oh that's not what I mean
what I mean is that you do find
something like sexual racism less so now
but sexual racism against let's say far
Asian leave you just use that phrase
what sexual racism
okay well sexual selectivity by
population against men in the same
population where women are fetishized
yeah okay now that's an interesting
evolutionary phenomenon and you know you
want to know how close what's the spices
dig there but the fetishization of for
instance East Asian women yep is that
not mostly by European and European
descended men or is there a Federation
of I mean I do dude this is crazy
conversation but you know do do South
American men fetish sighs East Asian
women and you know and if so is that
again harkening back to
something that emerges out of European
ethos that describes something
underlying I don't think it's arbitrary
at all is what I'm getting right I think
this is I I see that that's what you're
arguing yeah so first of all we've got a
confound which is it's very hard to sort
out what is the organic state of sexual
prejudice and what is the result of the
fact that you know if Asian women are
fetishized for some organic reason then
advertisers figure this out and they use
it to sell products and let feedback you
get positive here my point is you know
as you and I have seen repeatedly in
Central and South America our beauty
standards get broadcast by companies
into Latin America and so you know no
it's actually I mean no you could a lot
of different little rabbit holes here
but one of the really interesting things
about spending so much time both in
Latin America where you know by the
early 90s when we started going there
they were already completely immersed
and drenched in in Hollywood and Western
standards right whereas compare that to
Madagascar where we both spent a lot of
time I spent a bit more time than you
did also in the 90s which had almost no
exposure at all like in fact you know
would be if people asked us at all we
were from they would assume we're French
because America is just not in their in
their map at all of the world and it was
a very very different place to be you
know the the standards the expectations
and the beauty standards were very much
not in in the water in the air there and
and so decisions about who was
attractive and not we're very different
yeah they were very different but the
confound makes it difficult to know what
the organic state is in which
populations yeah be responding to which
prejudices in which populations have
picked up a prejudice because their
media is broadcasting and even if they
wouldn't have arrived there themselves I
guess I just don't think that you know
you I think you respond to the question
by saying absolutely not I don't think
that the idea of Western beauties
is itself wrong you are just saying you
okay but those standards are based on
something that is more fundamental and
I'm not claiming it's moral or or nice
but that is based on something that goes
deeper than just it's not arbitrary and
this you know this again is is the point
that we make over and over and over
again and this in this book that we're
working on that you know culture boy
cultural anthropology went off the rails
in the mid 20th century in part with
clifford geertz who was arguing in what
1960 70s that culture is arbitrary and
that therefore you can do all of this
work in cultural anthropology with the
assumption that what one culture does
could just as easily been what another
culture does and and no that's wrong
that's wrong culture evolves just like
just like eye color evolves and no it's
different mechanisms culture is not
genetic but be it genetic or
developmental or you know revealing
itself in anatomy or physiology or
behavioral or cultural it's all
evolutionary yeah it's passed by
different reddit area mechanisms but
it's an evolutionary landscape just the
same and we argue subservient to the
genetic landscape which is not a good
thing yeah well the cultural landscape
is flexible which is a great thing it
means we can change stuff in one
generation if we want to but the system
we've been handed is one in which
culture evolves to serve the genes and
if we want to break that linkage which
we should we've got our work cut out for
us
good I'm an economics undergrad trying
to figure out the best way to get my PhD
Brett I too struggle with school and
would love advice on how to succeed in
the system that doesn't work well for me
and you have any recommendations for
grad schools to teach in a unique way
well to the final question no they've
all disappeared unfortunately yeah no we
in some ways even the grad school that
worked for me is largely no more yeah so
I don't know what to say
well before you answer that first one to
the second question what I used to
advise our
my students are students when they were
considering going to grad school was at
least within the scientist I know less
about what goes on in economics that
most grad schools now you apply
basically to be working under someone in
their lab working on their questions so
you end up basically with a degree that
makes you a glorified lab tech you know
you've you've answered someone else's
questions that they have posed but their
hypotheses their predictions their
methods and maybe you get to do a little
troubleshooting of the methods along the
way but that's what you get your degree
for that so you get a PhD for my doctor
and philosophy for that
that's ridiculous whereas at Michigan at
least when we were there they had yeah
and that the the negative version of
what they had was it was sink or swim
you know I had a tremendous attrition
right you know half half of many of the
entering classes of PhD students at
Michigan failed out within the first few
years including I think our cohort
because you didn't just walk into you
know you had to you didn't go in and
work with someone else who had done the
thinking for you you had to generate
your own ideas your own hypotheses
figure out your own in our case you know
fieldwork you know cite and hypothesis
and you know everything and that meant
when you got to the end of it you
actually do in to do science because
you've done science and compare that to
a model in which it's easier it's more
predictable given that graduate students
are effectively really cheap labor for
these universities and these pis these
principal investigators it's more
reliable to make sure that once you let
them in they're going to be around for
five seven nine years however long it is
but if what you're actually trying to do
is generate free thinking independent
thinking scientists you want a school
that does not force you to slot into
someone else's lab and stay there no
matter what you know it's harder and
harder to find yeah Michigan's program
was evolutionary in more ways than one
you know it used selection to find the
people who could do the thing and didn't
do them how to do it and you know I
can't fault it entirely it does work
yeah but but it's also less like that
now you know that you have to do you
have to go in under someone and probably
you can switch but then it's hard to do
so and you sort of have this stigma
attached but to the to the first part of
the question
you know advice on how to succeed if you
don't if school doesn't like you well I
mean you know Eric and I had very
different experiences
I found an advisor who saw my my work as
valuable and was willing to do what was
necessary to in the end battle all the
way through am I getting my degree
Eric faced something very different so
it's not like I can say oh do that
because you may not be able to do that
but if you can I would say finding the
people who understand what you're up to
and why you should be there and are
willing to go to bat for you is
important and I would say make sure that
you you're doing what you need to do if
you've got to be there because the thing
that you really want to do in life
requires you to be there then do so but
don't kid yourself these systems they do
not produce people in the expectation
that there will be jobs they produce
people knowing that there will not be
jobs except for a very few and they
decide who's going to get the jobs and
if you're not their designated person
then you're liable to find that your
degree was in large measure or waste so
think carefully about what you're doing
next question are you concerned about
reports of bubonic plague in Colorado
and a new virus or illness in the
Central Asian states I think we
mentioned the plague in the last one or
two of these I actually have not seen
anything in the last week or so about
either of these but you know the idea of
highly transmissible potentially deadly
disease is obviously not a a small one
but with regard to plague we actually
have treatment for plague you know and
you have doxycycline is treatment for
plague and it's been the treatment for
plague for a long time plague was in
Madagascar when leave so when I was
there I think one of the times you were
there with me and just having you know a
lot of doxy on hand
in case you got infected was the
treatment yeah we never ran into it but
we see no evidence that the that is
evolving away from that drug in terms of
the drugs efficacy so it sounds
terrifying because we all have some
enough history to know what Europe
looked like in the in the second
millennium but but it's that particular
thing is probably not a major deal and I
don't remember exactly what the new
thing emerging in Central Asia is I
think it was a new flu strain of a
troubling kind but I haven't seen
anything h1n1 well that's more
frightening yep because you know the
thing about viruses is they reduce their
machinery to almost nothing and in so
doing they make it hard to fight them
because you can't attack their machinery
because it's your machinery they're
borrowing it so yeah I'm more concerned
about about the virus on the other hand
on the positive side we have now across
the entire planet had a proper or at
least the beginning of a proper
conversation about epidemiology and how
to prevent viruses from being spread hmm
and so my guess is even if h1n1 takes a
takes hold that we will have an easier
time fending it off I don't think I
understand this question what do you
think about right to repair in regard to
smartphones and their electronic devices
if you think it's important when you
consider talking to Jessa Johnson on
your podcast lots of love from poet I
think I don't know it means Mike it's
the right to fix your phone rather than
have to get a new one oh okay okay so it
was Zach off camera yeah so obviously in
a general sense we would be in favor of
this I
I like the ethos that if you can't open
it you don't own it and in lots of ways
we don't really own our phones you know
we rent our phones and they parasitize
us and it's not a fair relationship and
it's not symmetrical and we see this and
lots of things that aren't inherently
phone based you know we we obviously are
broadcasting this on YouTube and YouTube
makes decisions about whether the
content we are putting out is suitable
for its advertisers you know what they
didn't like the black intellectual
roundtable act you know actually
something ties them because offensive I
don't know danger dangerous I would the
dangerous No
so anyway the algorithm delivers a but
they have unsafety monetize that since
you I think so although I've seen it
I've seen them wobble in the past my
guess is what goes on is an algorithm
looks at the language or something and
if you're in territory that it finds it
all sensitive it did it punishes you for
making the content which is insane right
because this is exactly the content you
want in order to make the world less
dangerous so anyway I am going to policy
proposal this is not affiliated with
unity 2020 I think no matter what
happens there we have to do this other
thing which is artificial intelligence
that's the category we're shooting for
what we've got is artificial stupidity
so Google that's what you've achieved
and thank you for it I guess but could
you cut it out could you just leave us
alone could you trust us we put out good
stuff go through the channel look at it
or is anything really bad no so trust us
artificial swiftie the acronym for which
is ass yes we need another s somehow
somehow somehow yeah just a minute e
somehow okay hi both if you are not
already familiar checkout Jackson
Browne's I am a patriot and lives in the
balance both illustrate these times
powerfully I'm certain that he would
lend them to unity 20 2011 the UK
interest in nice can you talk to Billy
Bragg for us because he's gone nuts
okay I will do four more of these I was
trying to get through all the the orange
ones the $20 questions I probably won't
quite get through all of them though
sorry guys my child's uneducated barely
literate mother just start again okay
my child's uneducated barely literate
mother is getting dragged oh yeah I
haven't read this one yet I just I just
rank them I didn't read them my child's
uneducated barely literate mother is
anti school anti-vaxxer conspiracy
theorists too by the way I want her
educated because education was robbed
from me and I will never get my head
above water as a result
you seem Pro anti school please advise
oh yeah here's the thing there's that
cruddy thing that we call school and
then there's what school should be and
here's the key thing right civilization
is squandering human potential which is
despicable right a human is capable of
the most marvelous feats of compassion
and insight and innovation and yet we
take this spectacular creature and we
set it to the most mundane garbage right
we just waste everybody's time like not
just most of it all of it we waste
entire lives we we [ __ ] people by
exposing them to cruddy lessons that
don't cause them to be able to more be
more capable as adults it causes them to
be only capable of cog like behavior so
that's what school is school should be
the thing that figures out what the
limits of human capacity are we should
be moving in that direction we should be
discovering what school looks like and
so if you hear us ranting and railing
against school it's not because we don't
value what should be in that category
it's that we resent the amount of
squandering of human potential that
actually happens which is immense yeah
you know it's true that school is not
Universal in humans but learning is and
so one of the things that we speak to is
the idea that we have been handed
a false equivalency in which we are
basically told don't you want your
children to learn well then they have to
do it in school because where else could
they possibly learn and that's school
and learning aren't the same thing
that said school done well is frankly
what we were doing we were professional
educators for fifteen years
never having expected to to go into that
right and to this you know this book
that I read from the last hour this
weapons of mass instruction the subtitle
is is school teachers journey through
the dark world of compulsory schooling
so again you know this this author who
again rants and raves about the failures
of school himself also dedicated himself
for you know at least twice as long
maybe more than than we did to educating
Minds younger than his while still
recognizing exactly where the failings
in the system were so it's tough because
compulsory schooling is pretty broken
but there it's it's also it's extremely
difficult to do anything else you know
some of our most remarkable and
unexpected and brilliant students had
been homeschooled or unschooled at
Evergreen but that takes something that
takes a lot actually on the part of the
family and the parents and the kid and
most families just can't marriage that
either of those things so every time we
say this is what we were doing I think
it is important to say there were two
things necessary for us to do what we
were doing one was complete freedom to
do whatever we needed to do that freedom
was a disaster in other parts of the
college because it let people do nothing
right so the jobs were too easy to get
they weren't easy to get but they were
too easy to get so we brought in lots of
people who were lackluster and then we
couldn't get rid of them there was no
there was no standard by which they
could be judged and so evergreen
accumulated cruddy teachers however if
you were there and for your own reasons
you were motivated to try to figure out
how best to educate people nobody could
stop you right there was no compulsory
education inside of the structure you
could design your own courses and you
could teach them and you had your
students attention full-time so you had
an incredible
palette on which to paint and so for
those of us like you and me the small
number who were just absolutely driven
to figure out what you could teach given
complete freedom it was great
and these two things that we separated
but it worked much more effectively for
older so not only where we teach in
college not k12 but also many of our
students were older than traditional age
you know whatever green across the board
I think the average age of the students
was 25 or so and we often had students
our age or older and so we had a palette
that we could share with our students
and and paint onto a canvas that was
open as opposed to the kind of
paint-by-numbers top-down authoritarian
approach that most modern compulsory
schooling engages in and part of that a
little bit of that probably has to
happen because you do need to know how
to write and you're not going to know
you're not gonna learn how to write by
just hanging out in the forest that's
not where you're gonna learn how to
write but the the sort of No Child Left
Behind and all of its bastard children
and the standardized testing and the
amount of time taken up in the
curriculum - teaching - and then the
follow on after all the standardized
tests that are now taking up so much
time of children is rendering teachers
unable to do the kind of work that even
the best of them the best of them would
be able to do had they a bit more
freedom to actually do their jobs yeah
also as great as it is to do that job at
the level of college it is really
important that we start doing the job
for the youngest kids because the longer
you wait the harder it is to to
resurrect an awake mind yep okay this
question is about biology hash tag
biology is invasive species quote the
religion of biology in that to question
the ideas heresy and results in
excommunication it appears to the right
to the question asker that invasive
species are opportunistic species and a
point in time is preferred yeah so
there's something to this it's sort of
kinda yeah sort of kind of let's put it
this way you've got
take people out of the equation you've
got some sort of mechanism that produces
an equilibrium of species in each
habitat right so you've got a certain
amount of species migration or a species
that wasn't in a habitat finds its way
into a habitat you've got a certain
amount of emergence of new species
through speciation and these things tend
to equilibrate every so often something
will disperse over a very long distance
I've talked about the fact that the only
mammal that is natively on land in
Hawaii is a bat okay some point a bat
that wasn't in Hawaii got blown off
course maybe a pregnant bat or maybe it
was a couple bats that were flying
together that got blown there and it
happened to be a male and a female who
knows but some how about that wasn't in
Hawaii ended up there is that natural of
course is it invasive I wouldn't call it
that it's a natural process so when we
say invasive what we really mean are
human transported creatures where we
have solved a biological problem by
transporting a creature over a gap that
would not have crossed and that is
resulted in it not having to solve that
problem and therefore sometimes being
competitively superior and driving out
species that are native so if what you
oppose is the human transportation of
creatures and therefore solving a
problem that they were evolutionarily
unable to solve on their own then this
all makes sense so invasive doesn't mean
migrant it means human driven invasive
and human driven invasives are often
competitively superior because they are
not hamstrung by they need to disperse
into the habitat and they often don't
have competitors or predators or
parasites within their new habitat that
have millions of years of coevolution
with them yeah so they are freed from
any of the constraints of their the
native organisms which they are more
close most closely aligned with niche
wise so they can move into someone
else's niche and not suffer the same
kind of parasites pathogens competitors
predators as the native organisms do and
thus have a better chance of taking over
so the ultimate thing here is if you
take human transportation
of creatures out of the equation you
will get high diversity if humans are
allowed to transport things willy-nilly
because we decide invasion it's just
another natural process you will drive
diversity through the floor and the
reason is because you will find the same
superior competitors everywhere and if
you don't believe us look at eucalyptus
I really wrecking South America in
Portland English ivy English ivy here
yeah eucalyptus every sack is now
laughing because he knows this is some
of the beans of my existence yes I go
out every week and tear out as much of
the English ivy as I can not because
when I'm in England I hate ivy but it
has no business here and it destroys the
huckleberries and the salal and the
sword ferns and the vine maples and
everything else that would make a
beautiful and productive forest which
when you take out the ivy you get back
the creepers and the wrens and the
woodpeckers and everything else as well
and that's just the birds yeah but you
know English ivy comes in and you end up
with a mono crop that as opposed to an
actual rich diverse ecosystem okay next
so questions now from this live stream
have you read the critiques of fryers
and empirical analysis of racial
differences cited by Harris they are
weak but it might be useful to discuss
for those who are unable to parse their
weakness I'm not aware of this I don't
know I don't know by that name by Harris
cited by Harris excited by I don't just
says Harris okay not sure yep Bret your
first against the wall club needs a
better name I suggest the 300 referring
to the 300 Spartans Oh from Thermopylae
okay we will take that under advisement
we will perhaps put it to a vote at the
next meeting of the first against the
wall club say you have not been you got
into the wall pushback from both me and
your brother which you know it's it's
it's somewhat rare that it's the two of
us opposing an idea in very much the
same words definitely now you're always
dealing with opposing but you don't
agree with each other very frequently
about the direction of opposition but in
this case you do seem to be Alliant that
that is an appalling designation which
makes me pretty sure it's right okay and
I'm determined to win you both over not
300 then
thermopylae it's a good word Thermopylae
is a great word yeah yeah okay
next question we are white
eight year old girl six year old boy I
don't know what this question means we
are white eight year old girl six year
old boy
anti racism parenthesis full doctrine
greater than Dei meaning diversity
equity and inclusion greater than their
k12 school is this legal
this discriminates at its core and calls
us racists I suspect I suspect there's
something going on at the school with
regard to the diversity equity and
inclusion movement but I can't I can't
translate I know you were limited by
letters here so I'm not not faulting the
person who wrote the question but I
can't translate it enough to to say I
don't get it
yeah yeah sorry certain evils involve a
most of us aren't consensus yes as an
intellectual trade-off making zero day
arguments abundant Drive fuel their day
exploits I'm concerned that a pedophile
fragility illustration could escape the
rhetorical lab at this point tried to
put more and more so certain evils
excuse me certain evils involve in most
of us aren't consensus as if
intellectual trade-off okay yeah so like
hashtag not all been yeah you know white
people never true F making zero day
arguments abundant dry fuel so what's
the zero day well zero day exploit would
be something that works because nobody
sees it coming that once they've
encountered it they learn to to fend it
off okay and then I'm concerned that a
pedophile fragility illustration which
is something we read last time it was a
question that came in as a oh it was an
analogy to prove the falsity of the way
fertility I'm concerned that the
pedophile fertility illustration could
escape the rhetorical lab at this point
oh yeah but I think the point is that
there is no bar to this argument the
reductio ad absurdum is going to be just
a
dokdo add my Latin is about film but it
the argument that was at one time useful
to point out the absurdity of a position
is going to become a position which
we've seen that doesn't you know sex is
not a binary yeah you know no and
actually I mean there there are some
really horrifying and creepy pedophilia
justifying claims already beginning to
move around the well I mean what we see
in the you know the drag kids stuff like
what what the heck is this yeah it's so
yeah reading to you know pre-k kids and
library reading hours sexualized oh yeah
oh god yeah okay next up do you think
that apprenticeship or rites of passage
should become more common in the West as
a lot of men specifically seem to lack
guidance well I would say a lot of men
and women seem to lack guidance that
rites of passage have been not totally
ubiquitous in every human culture that
has been looked at but nearly so is some
I mean I I think actually so this is
terrific book I kind of I think it's
David last name Brown called human
universals human universals and which he
basically tries to assess what are in
fact some of the many traits that show
up in every single culture that has been
looked at and while he says he's not
quite sure that rites of passage are
universal I think when I look carefully
at the data he's using I would say
actually while say you know death ritual
isn't totally Universal marriage which
will doesn't totally peel birth ritual
if you if you go across all the kinds of
rituals coming-of-age being the one that
is being alluded to here I think every
culture does have some kind of some kind
of ritual for sure but then rites of
passage
almost all of them do yeah we lost
something real and graduation from high
school and for many people going to
college and graduating from college used
to be for you know a couple of decades
any
a kind of rite of passage but it's it's
not that anymore because it doesn't have
very much more thing is it's not it's
lots in yeah but it has none of the
useful characteristics so in any case we
do make exactly this argument in our
book that rites of passage are
fundamental that their loss breaks an
important phenomenon and that something
needs to take its place I mean and it's
a perfect test in Spence situation where
you may not be able to pay exactly what
the rite of passage does and you may say
it's archaic but if you eliminate it
then you discover that oh hey why are
there no adults yeah hey I wonder I
wonder why I wonder why there are no
adults and apprenticeship absolutely I
mean there there are some kinds of work
that really just mandate apprenticeship
and we're losing it nearly across the
board and then you might argue that even
that kind of work that doesn't
necessarily require apprenticeship might
benefit from it both from the
perspective of the master and the
apprentice yeah it's great for some
things carpentry for example not so good
for sorcerers it can cause a lot of
trouble yeah yeah
brooms gonna have an exam in all too
easily all too easily hey Zach I'm
hearing a lot of cat Bell you wanna you
want to let the cat in so he stops going
operatic on us okay where were we here
we go I want to hear your ideas on
California ooh I just scrolled away too
far there we go want to hear your ideas
on California Prop 16 in which civil
rights will be on the ballot in November
and can be struck down to commit
positive discrimination to increase
black and Latino college admissions yeah
we we mentioned we talked about this a
little bit a few episodes back I don't
think we identified it by I did by the
name
yeah but prop 16 on the California
ballot so yeah I mean it it should be
pretty clear to people who follow us
what we're likely to think about this
which is that this is you know it's the
very leading edge of something that is
about to overwhelm us which is that
these positive discrimination which is
of course not positive in any useful
sense of that term is going to be
installed into every system both
formally and in
formerly and civilization will come
apart as a result so yeah bad really as
bad as it could be and you know will
that one initiative be the the thing
that heralds the end of Western
civilization probably not but it does
tell you what's coming down the pike
okay I'm reading someone else's
assessment here Epstein and Maxwell ran
a mossad backed blackmail ring on global
elites the leaders of both parties are
implicated incredible sexual assault
allegations with the contemporaneous
evidence please take time to review
Whitney Webb's investigative journalism
okay yeah I don't either but you know
Eric has talked extensively about what
might account for the epstein phenomenon
and yeah it's a possibility
this is Fairfax everyone do
consumer-grade UV black lights kill
kovat and if so should we make cosmic
bowling the new national pastime yes and
definitely yes yes sure yes I believe
they do there is a fair amount of work
now on different types of UV and how
effective they are but I think even the
ones that are least effective are still
effective enough to be useful so yes yes
to the bowling and you know transport
early Jurassic right Oh what did we
dress I had wear as much white as
possible because then it cities up the
black line you don't end up with a
bowling ball through you know it's not a
safety thing it's a cool thing I see
yeah safety third as I once said to
students things you could regret saying
in court yes yes yes it was a day in
which no one almost died so I was it
worked out yeah you guys don't think
consciousness you know you guys don't
think conscious awareness is fundamental
but without it nothing would matter do
you really think a universe in which
nothing matters could
could spontaneously produce the capacity
to matter they think you've completely
must understood our position conscious
oh well it's it's fundamental okay so it
depends on what you mean by fundamental
so there's a couple of different
meanings in the word fundamental here
yes it matter humans wouldn't be humans
without consciousness but the idea that
consciousness is fundamental and that
item that it came before it matter
and it's primary is is the thing that we
say no yeah that's pen psychism and and
no that doesn't work that's what makes
sense or even even just before creatures
would be absurd so I think you have a
couple of what Daniel Dennett calls
deputies in here weird I think this
actually may be tongue-in-cheek this
question somebody's messing with us yeah
all right well it's good it's good
through the green who's who's asked
questions for do you really think
University much nothing yeah I think
he's exactly playing was a fundamental
in matter here alright well he feels me
and me too
okay yeah fair enough we're up though
why don't you answer it in good fun I
was going to argue the panel I think
there are two deputies in that statement
a Dipity being a term that shifts
meaning inside of a claim that results
in a false paradox so what is the famous
example I can't remember I don't know it
has to do with has to do with love being
just a word and the idea is that love is
actually a phenomenon but it's also a
word and so if you slide between those
two meanings you can create logical
problems yeah so anyway I think matter
and matter mm-hmm is playing that role
yeah yeah okay and fundamental to it's
just not sliding actively within this
framing does the fact that there are
less Y chromosomes than Metin explained
behaviors like group rape where Y has
the probability to be passed even if
without the rest of the genome is group
rape more probable if the Y is shared
within the group
this is asked by a woman incidentally
which at least changes my yes last part
of the question is possible yeah but
never thought of it before but it would
have to be triggered by the y-chromosome
carrying sequences that would function
in their own interest mm-hmm which is
unlikely given the nature of Y
chromosomes that we actually find in
other words it may be why the Y
chromosomes have been genetically
largely shut down but anyway it's not
it's not impossible that such a thing
could evolve although I guess the
question is why why is the Y crime if
the Y chromosome is shared then it
doesn't really have an interest in more
than one male participating and their
mating unless by the way in order for
this to be an acceptable thing for us to
be discussing I think we have to be
discussing insects or something like
that
okay which of course don't have yeah it
was almost sex determination yeah
Duval's all right voles it is sorry
voles if there any voles watching
we apologize I'm not apologizing to
voles
it must be later than the podcast we've
gotten to whether or not we're
apologizing to voles
yeah so the question is what's the
advantage to the chromosome of getting
more than one male involved it's not
obvious to me that there is one yeah but
could such a thing emerge evolutionarily
yes if there was a sequence carried on
the y chromosome that could advance its
own interest in this way there of course
lots of other systems that have the same
nature but not the same mechanism of
action like driving genetic elements
that cause themselves to be in a larger
fraction of gametes than they would be
in normally sometimes by killing off
some fraction of gametes so that the
fertilizing gamete
always carries the element this comes at
a fitness cost to the individual but it
advances the interest of the element in
question so those things exist and I
think that's
kind of the model for what you're
looking for here yeah sorry my
interesting question next okay let's do
a few more someone is saying again as we
talked about the end of the last live
stream Barry Weiss resigned from the New
York Times because it was a hostile work
environment
owing to political orthodoxy yeah that's
that's very much it next question
well actually as long as they were on
that topic here's the hostile work
environment that's illegal
the employer has an obligation to
correct that now here's the question
would a court be able to hear that
argument at court is certainly supposed
to hear that argument but at the moment
it might be impossible to get a court to
give her a judgment that there was a
hostile work environment and you know we
found the rudiments of this as we were
fixing to to sue the state for allowing
Evergreen to be a hostile work
environment and the problem was in the
courts there was already this woke
ideology that you know made them more
interested in painting us as as racist
than in engaging the fact that they
actually had people roving a campus with
baseball bats hunting professors I mean
come on yeah so it's a question mm-hmm
next question in the same vein why do
human beings enjoy the sound of birdsong
mmm I love this question yeah I mean I
think this one is it's let's put it this
way the first order answer is easy we
look for proxies for productivity why do
you find a particular valley beautiful
and another one inhospitable that's
gonna tend to correlate to how likely
you are to be able to find things that
your ancestors might have eaten there or
to grow things that your ancestors might
have grown there so you can imagine that
we could have all kinds of creatures
function it's like an omen that says yes
this is the spot and the yes this is the
spot creature it's just one that tends
to be seen in places that are good and
doesn't tend to be seen in places that
are bad so this is probably wrong but
one thing that occurs to me is that one
of the leading hypotheses for why
primates experienced an adaptive
radiation when they did which is you
know the earliest primates existed
before the KT boundary before Chicxulub
hit what's now the Yucatan about 65
million years ago six million years ago
but that we really expanded quite a bit
afterwards and that this was the
expansion was yes about the opening of
niches as all the non-avian dinosaurs
were now out of the way but one of the
hypotheses also has to do with the
coevolution of angiosperms of flowering
plants and if because primates are
largely like songbirds frugivores or
many songbirds are pollinators as well
but frugivores or insectivorous the
insects themselves being effective
radiated so if all if all of these
things promotes were in part Co evolving
along with angiosperms or flowering
plants I suspect although I know much
less about how we've mapped songbird
evolutions of songbirds is a is a real
group it's passerines it's a real
evolutionary group I suspect that they
also experienced an adaptive radiation
with angiosperms and flowering plants
because how could they not they were
mostly eating the same stuff so it's
possibly the primates and songbirds are
both sort of mapped on to the same
moment in plant evolution and that if we
were all adaptively radiating at the
same time we would have come to
basically have our aesthetic at a most
fundamental level be that with whom we
were evolving at the same time although
not exactly Co evolving because we
aren't dependent on songbirds for the
most part they aren't big enough to for
us to be eating them and they're mostly
birds and mammals are eating different
seeds of different toxins different
preferences but it could have been a
sort of emerging life at the same time
and such as such a shared vision of
beauty yep I mean there was a lot in
that explanation I like it it's like I
said it's probably wrong because there's
two hinges on too much at some level but
I'm cautiously betting in favor of it
all right and I would say that the you
know
we really at the end it's just basically
then songbirds are a proxy for a
productive angiosperm ecosystem in which
plants are paying to have their seeds
distributed yeah that's likely to be a
good place for people yeah yeah I love
that question more questions like that
yeah that's a good one what role has
postmodernist thinking played in the
recent protests and riots is the school
of thought plus social media what drives
behavior to engage with only the
periphery of info part of the root cause
that went a little off the rails at the
end but yeah yeah I mean this many of
our most recent live streams have been
to this question and most of the people
on the street wouldn't be able to name
post modernist thinker probably some of
them could because they've been schooled
in it I schooled
I used the word schooled intentionally
but the fact that many people couldn't
tell you about Foucault or Derrida or
Marcus or whoever doesn't mean that
that's it's not emerging from this these
critical theories which is a direct
outgrowth of post-modernism yeah I think
our friends
Helen pluck Rosen Jim Lindsey and Jim
Lindsay and Helen pluck rose well Helen
pluckers and Jim Lindsey specifically
have a book out in August of this year
that's already available for pre-order
we've got a copy on the way to us right
now so I'm not ready yet but I'm sure
I'm just I'm certain it's excellent
called cynical theories in which they
well they deconstruct have the D
constructionists and I believe go after
specifically you know that the claims of
you know racism and sexism and
transphobia and ableism and you know fat
phobia and all of these things by going
back to the so-called primary literature
and pointing out the origins of these
things yes I was gonna say was that they
have a term they use which is I think
it's functional postmoderns
and they might have heard the idea being
you don't need to know you don't need to
know that you're operating a postmodern
philosophy in order to operate one and
so the
they don't know Derrida is immaterial
hmm do you need a software engineer with
15 plus years of experience to build a
cloud infrastructure docker streaming
etc I want to contribute hmm we might
well maybe um yeah Zack you want it it's
51
how does Unity 2020 hope to deal with
Congress but you think they will
Stonewall you especially since both
sides will hate you have any plans to
put up candidates for Congress that last
question is one we haven't heard before
so you have said we're not gonna go into
details because we don't want them to
see us coming wellzyn level let's put it
this way we can talk about the Congress
issue first of all there are a lot of in
every place in the system you have
people who are going to operate
according to the corrupt modality of the
system because frankly it's the smart
thing to do right you can starve
yourself by not participating you can be
a jerk and you can be corrupt no matter
what or you can function according to
the rules of the system as you find them
and hope for better rules and so some
fraction of the Congress is going to be
people who would love to be freed but
here's the thing for unity 2020 to work
we need a groundswell sufficient to
draft these candidates that groundswell
is a credible threat against people who
Stonewall in the Congress in other words
the reason that this can succeed is that
people are livid at how they are being
treated by their government to the
extent that you have people in Congress
who find themselves faced with a
presidential team that has been elected
specifically to drain the swamp there is
an incentive to declare yourself not of
the swamp to take a pledge perhaps that
would prevent you from participating in
swamp like behavior and I believe there
are many ways that this could function
so it's not it's not a small issue but
let's just say the groundswell that
tells the apparatus that we are
completely sick of being treated this
way and being parasitized is the key not
only to changing
the people in the White House but to
change into Congress okay we're gonna
make quickly go through these six okay
knowing that we're going well beyond our
our John mentioned a change in black
communities between 1960 and 1980 I
don't know if this is my probably
McWhorter rather than would junior I
believe so but ain't here more okay so
John this is a reference to the black
intellectuals roundtable which you
moderated that was posted on this
channel yesterday John mentioned and had
two of the men named John John McWhorter
and John Wood jr. John mentioned a
change in black communities between
nineteen sixty and eighty could this be
linked to the change in black music from
the love and peace values of Motown to
violence money and objectifying women in
rap especially for young black men yes
and no that is very interesting my guess
is the music is a symptom and that in
effect what you have is a a pattern in
which it is clear that the hope for
trajectory has been abandoned right that
something is now in the way right so you
had the hopeful progress of the civil
rights movement and then you have
something get derailed and I guess the
point is people who find that a system
is no longer responsive to their needs
become cynical about it and rebellious
against it and they generate their own
culture that no longer participates so
you know I don't want to claim to know
more about it than I do
but I do think you have to ask yourself
the question just the shift in music
over the same period of time doesn't
tell you whether that is a symptom of
the same phenomenon or whether it is
causal and my guess is it isn't causal
that the nature of music in human beings
is that it's going to track our mindsets
rather than
drive them just to get back to the
question
they do say linked so that doesn't
although I also I read it as you did as
could it be causal the idea of linkage I
think is actually almost certain now
that you say it I mean it does it does
match the greater cultural change and so
you know probably there's interplay back
and forth but more likely the music is
affect there is another factor though
that we have to cover which is that the
Motown era was accompanied by some
predatory business practices against
black artists in the extreme so lots of
black artists who produced really
important music and had a powerful
influence were just shut out of the
benefits of what they had created and so
and the music itself was also altered by
the fact that in some sense part of what
it did was appeal to black audiences but
part of what it did was appeal to white
audiences too and so there's a lot of
stuff that might not have been
organically produced in the black
community that was nonetheless saleable
and so there's kind of a presentation of
black culture that was more palatable to
white culture and to the extent that
black artists rightly got more powerful
got more credit got more of the money
from the music they produced they also
became independent of that structure and
so I don't know how all those things fit
together but my guess is that what we
are seeing partly is constraint in the
Motown era and that the removal of some
of that constraint resulted in a very
different presentation okay five more
dear Heather and Bret I would love to
see a list of books you recommend you
two are great I do have on my patreon at
the $17 tier various lists of
recommended books I've got a list of
science books I recommend I just put up
some science fiction and every time I
walk by our bookshelves that you
installed in our house when we moved
here having lost our office space and
our extensive libraries when we left
Evergreen I think I just I loved being
able to have the books that we have and
wish we had even more space for more of
them not I thought you necessarily often
experience but but yeah I do I do have
some up some such lists up next question
what are your thoughts on the letter
unjustice and open debate published July
7th and Harper's have either of you
thought about signing it we were not
asked to sign it I would not have signed
it would you have signed it I don't
think so but it's hard to know yeah it's
easy to say probably not but I think we
should cover this I I thought we might
get to it today and we didn't but I must
say I am very troubled by that letter
not so much for what it does say but how
it divides people who naturally are not
to be divided must not be divided and
anyway so I found the letter very
troubling that said we have a tremendous
number of friends on that list who
signed that letter and so they in some
sense have been dragged into something I
think my guess is they would have the
same complaints about it that we would
so let's cover it more in detail next
time oh this is this is from someone who
I think we ended with last time with
regard to the white fragility book club
and we had said we're not sure what kind
of you know what your person of color
status is and therefore what you might
be able to do if you are walking into a
white fragility book club with mostly
middle-class white women it's just I
think what I remember you saying the
rest of the people were you say hello
again a mixed Latino and Persian with
Marxist immigrant parents I am a male
cultural Christian and libertarian and
the first person with my last name to be
a citizen and get a decree love thank
you wow that's awesome and I would be
curious to know how
that went to that book club what if you
did it a penultimate question here just
a comment reach out to biologists in
Alaska it's really complicated Barrow
and Wolf seasons are managed around
moose etc okay I'm prepared to be wrong
about bears but I I just have a soft
spot in my heart for them yeah you do
okay final question for today hi Heather
and Bret have you considered having
Michael Shellenberger on the podcast he
shares your concerns about the climate
crisis but comes to different
conclusions about nuclear power he comes
to different conclusions about a lot of
things and I must say I have
occasionally seen Michael Shellenberger
say things that I agree with but I am
very frequently alarmed by the
perspective that he arrives at so it's
not that I wouldn't consider talking to
him I would but I would say to those of
you who are watching Michael proceed
with caution
where where he talks about nuclear power
I feel he is clearly dead wrong and
dangerously so and I suspect a hidden
agenda that has something to do with
perverse incentives you want me to you
want to end there like I said or do you
want to and not on Shellenberger that's
fine we can end on schellenberg okay
that's it then that's it well sir you
have survived another Dark Horse
livestream Q&A with Brett and Heather
we'll be back on what is today today is
Tuesday today is Tuesday we will be back
on Saturday we're gonna you're gonna be
back on Saturday I'm gonna get hourly
yes of course but you're not gonna be
sitting there the whole time trying to
get out of this chair really soon I
might even get on a bicycle nice yeah
yeah all right well thanks for joining
us we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]